now people often tell me there's no such
thing as cancer culture it doesn't exist
it's in my head
but it does exist it's very real
it involves delusional mobs who shame
abuse and vilify anyone who dares share
an opinion that doesn't conform to their
own narrow world view
here's a clip from a trans pride parade
in london on saturday
[Applause]
lovely people there's no question that
we can change our gender we can do it by
mutilating ourselves we can remove bits
of our body and therefore change our
shape and so on but you can't change
your sex because that is embedded
actually in those genes in every cell in
the body we don't normally see this kind
of footage and it's extremely harrowing
but perhaps the most disturbing part of
it is the inaction of all these armed
police what did you make of it
well it is almost impossible to explain
the unexplainable the remarkable thing
about this is how underwhelming they all
are actually i mean rishi sooner i was a
big fan before the whole non-dom
revelation about his wife i thought that
was the most extraordinarily
naive thing to have done to have allowed
happen i think he's completely tainted
i'm afraid by his long
service with boris johnson and presiding
over historic taxes and i think he's
going to have a real problem convincing
the tory party membership he's suddenly
gone from being written off about a
month ago because of the red hot
favorite now we're not quite sure so now
i just don't think he's going to
convince the uh the members ava who i
mean you know you're obviously from the
other side on all this but who of them
has most impressed you as a politician
penny definitely she's come out of total
obscurity she was very impressive
yesterday i thought yeah she was and
she's she's great she's [ __ ] she's
really you know engaging she's
interesting and she doesn't have that
awful continuity candidate reek about
her that the other two do is he good for
the game is the question
a day later you and i are talking about
him you've got an opinion yeah i've got
an opinion and he's really good at the
game too because you don't make women
and finally he's good but i think he got
out psyched by djokovic who just got
cool who's mcdonald's
i saw this old man
hold in a
a little gray kitten
and
the mill the old man survived his house
being bombed
and
he lost five family members
and the only thing he had
kind of hard for me to talk about it
the only thing he had was this little
grey kitty
you don't think tom cruise is a is a
good actor
i think he's irrelevant in my world
well i'm joined now by prue leath lovely
to talk to you
hello pierce
this is a very serious subject and
opinions have been raging on both sides
about it
why do you feel so passionately about
this issue
well i suppose because i'm 82 and
heading for the big decision
um
but
i i really i mean i i started getting
interested in the whole subject when my
um elder brother died and he died
a really horrible death um
and recently my younger brother died and
he
died at home with his family around him
and
he didn't have assisted suicide because
he didn't need it but he had the sort of
death that i think that
people who want assisted suicide
um would dearly love to have i'm giving
the opportunity to try and explain why a
god loves you tall can't extend to
loving gay people right
god made us male and female
and he designed sex between to be
between a man and a woman and not
between two women and not two men that's
the way god made us and created us and
it's just the way it is what if what if
they're gay and they feel that they want
to have sex with people
like them well it's i'm just saying it's
the bible calls it sin and i'll care
enough about it by the bible it's you as
well call it right well my point is i
know lots of gay people who are far less
sinful in my estimation than lots of
straight people i know sure
and i don't understand why i should be
free and you should be free to have sex
with who we like but gay people come no
you don't have sex with whoever you like
it's between a marriage relationship
between a man and a woman and that's the
way god designs do you understand why
gay people and people who have no issue
with gay people feel so strongly about
the comments you've said well first of
all i i don't hate gay people and i
don't preach against gay people and i
don't go demonstrate against gay people
you'll never see where i've said
anything bad about the gay people i just
you just have you just don't realize no
i i believe you just said it's fine for
straight people to have sex with each
other but can i know but can i not have
the views that i believe god wants us to
you're entitled to your view frankly you
are entitled to your views